der geborene kommen ja was geht und
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
ich bin heute bei luca wie viele diese
wunderschönen lampe erkennt wir haben
dafür lukas größte pizzastück der welt
gebacken und ich weiß nicht ob ich
wusste damals absoluter liebling
schokoriegel ist neckars und luca meint
ist okay ich mache das nächste
pizzastück der welt wie wär's mit dem
größten sneakers der welt keine sorge
übrigens wir haben später noch gäste und
werden das zu zehnt oder so hoffentlich
auf essen aber der plan ist sneakers ein
snickers ein snickers dass wir so ein
riesiges mitmachen und dann überziehen
wir das mit geschmolzener schokolade und
haben am ende ein gigantischen berg
wegen wir doch erst mal kommen
[Musik]
junge ist so schönes gefühl
buttons mclaren brüssel nur das 10 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
habt ihr das gesehen wir packen es erst
mal dieses zeug
danke dass sich der effekt sogar mit so
einem guss den us open ist das größte
schiff der welt gefallen
absicht war das egal
das ganze sieht zwar extrem ungesund aus
aber ich frage euch beraten
wir haben das rezept von weight watchers
und wir haben so gesagt also solange wir
nicht zwei von diesen riesigen sneakers
180 gästen sind ist nicht so schlimm wie
gesagt ja die sagen sogar ist kann sich
sogar gut dass die figur auswirken ja
wenn man in maßen diese risiken regel
ist also vielleicht zu zwei die woche
oder so ja was eigentlich
a
apophis ja sogar weiter da bahia leute
wenn man konzentriert ewigkeiten schon
keine schokolade mehr gegessen und haben
wird die hälfte davon alleine essen
einfach so leiter der ganze spaß hier
ist jetzt fertig und ich habe mir
überlegt dass wir quasi um so eine form
zu machen für das für das riesen
sneakers wir lassen uns jetzt mal auf
kleiner flamme stehen und die grundform
zu machen leute die machen ja sechs
stück quasi als grundlage haben jetzt
überlegt ich weiß nicht hier sind weil
das ist kann ja für so eine kleine form
daraus machen wo wir das zeug basiert
rein machen damit es irgendwie kriegen
vorn behält
ok dafür das ist jetzt mehr oder weniger
fertig machen eben die ecken nur
fachlich aus glaube aber das ist endlich
zeit wenn man muss auch auf der
unterseite ist ein bisschen okay leute
das ist diese provisorische form die ich
jetzt gebastelt habe und ich würde sagen
wir gehen einfach mal rüber holen uns
die geschmolzene schokolade glaube wir
haben es zu lang so aufstellen dass das
jetzt noch ein bisschen rockig geworden
selberbacken schon wieder fehler gemacht
das denn
[Musik]
wir müssen die dinge erst auspacken
irgendwie cooler typ
ich habe wieder wird das wir machen okay
wer es nicht abwarten kann noch so auch
immer mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
skateboards richten nur noch keiner
stoppen müssen also leute wir machen
jetzt quasi die grundlage so dass ganze
verteilt sich jetzt mal bitten und jetzt
nehmen wir dieses niveaus und packen sie
einfach seite an seite seite dann
gelungen
dann machen wir so ein layer dazwischen
war schokoladenmasse schokolade dieser
gerichte haben sich lange an schokolade
dass jemand der gerade 16 sneakers
zusammenklebt sagt es langt nicht an
schokolade für sich dass er gerade den
größten ist er gast der welt was ich
jemals gefahren
und last but not least meine form ist
nicht so gut wie ich dachte jetzt kommt
es darauf an leute die ganze restliche
schokolade kommt jetzt drüber und es ist
können wieder von anderen nicht gefällt
was wird sozusagen die wird es ein
kunstwerk bisher als sicher dafür
schreiben sie dann nur aus die dünnen
schild behalte aber es ist wundervoll
leckerbissen das trotzdem natürlich ist
das aber erst mal gold
ich glaube aber hin zu recht stolz
darauf und es wird einfach unglaublich
was niklas hat auch immer so ein ding
obendrauf ne max mir jetzt hast du auch
einen schokoriegel noch etwas luft nach
oben drauf hat
[Musik]
dieser scheißegal ist das ganz viel
schokolade isst wird schon gut schmecken
oder so leute es ist jetzt eine ganze
weile vergangen aber es ist jetzt alles
getrocknet und mein gott ist das ding
schwer da sieht man es noch ein bisschen
hier ist schon als extrem hart und hier
ist noch so ein ganz bisschen weil ich
es aber auch außen rum ist ja das sieht
die mega geil aus wird es halt echt hart
aber jeder hasst wie olga 7 gedacht
jetzt sagen wir packen das jetzt mal aus
dieser
provisorischen verpacken das alter
jedoch dass du so einfach abgesetzt und
auch ein bisschen überrascht die einfach
passiert wie geil dieses niklas aus der
natur
es geht ja eh scheiße jedoch erstmal
kommt dass katia fällt kann es einfach
raus geben mit der kamera wieder nach
afrika ist nicht so gut wie die unsere
ins rollen heißt also improvisierte idee
funktioniert hat ne also wie geil das
einfach aussieht man wird ist richtig
gut geworden
das ist richtig gut geworden so vor
indem man denkt so von oben das ist von
kaka aber ich meine sogar normale
sneaker sieht so aus von oben ein liga
del das sieht so aus als hätten einzelne
nüsse drin und so hier ist echt so
läutet muss mit platz und freiraum
verschaffen damit ich dieses gigantische
sneakers lassen kann
ich habe da so popp daraus man guckt
euch diese bauen wir mal ein alter
vielleicht blende ich euch jetzt mal ein
wie viel kalorien was ging hat das in
einer form ihr liebhaber und leute wir
testen sie jetzt einfach ich bin so
gespannt wie das jetzt schmeckt meint
dass eigentlich nur sneakers also
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schwankend
du musst einfach mal dass sie zu lecker
schmeckt die größte sneakers riegel der
welt mit durchgeschnitten
dieses geld aus das papier soll also
werden auf jeden fall diese dinge laufe
des abends auch etwas ist der up und für
waren zukünftig machen ist das ganz
normal viel perverser dass das so ein
riesiges dinge ist wo du rein weiß ich
würde empfehlen so viele partys oder so
ist das echt nice also wenn ihr dann ein
paar leute als besuch bekommt die alles
mitmachen
ansonsten schaut wieder vorbei das
neueste pizzastück der weltgrößten
sachen der welt aber und sehen uns beim
nicht mal wieder weihnachten